رغم ان العديد من المنظمات الحقوقيه دقت
ناقوس الخطر حول خطوره الزواج قبل سن ال
18 عاما الا ان مشكله زواج القاصرات
مستمره دراسه محليه حديثه تقول ان 90% من
الفتيات المتزوجات تحت سن 18 عاما ذكرنا
انهن اضطررن الى ترك المدرسه بعد عقد
قرنهم وبالتاكيد تواجه الفتاه المتزوجه
بحسب الدراسه مشاكل متعدده ولا تستطيع
حلها نتيجه ضعف امكانياتها وقدرتها
الدراسات تشير الى ان الفتاه المتزوجه
تحتاج العديد من المقومات والمهارات
الحياتيه وهي معرضه للمخاطر الصحيه
كالاجهاض المزيد حول هذه القصه مع لميس
ابراهيم
التشريع الاردني يمنع الزواج كليا قبل
بلوغ سن الرشد المعتمد 18 عاما ولكنه في
الوقت ذاته سمح بالزواج في سن 16 في حالات
خاصه واذا سوف جمله من الشروط وتشمل الفئه
العمريه لزواج القاصرات ما بين 18 الى 15
عاما حيث يبلغ عدد زاج القاصرات في الاردن
بين 11 او حتى 10,000 سنويا في دراسه
اعدتها منظمته السيد
فقط من الاناث التي تمت مقابلتهن انهن
وصلنا تعليمهن بينما تسرب 92% منهم وكان
سبب الاكبر الذي تم الاستشهاد به للتسرب
للمدرسه هو مسؤوليات الزواج بنسبه
46% يليها رفض الزوج بنسبه 13% وعدم
الاهتمام بمواصله التعليم بنسبه 12% وفي
الوقت نفسه ذكرت الدراسه انه عند سؤال
القاضي عما اذا كان قد طلب تاكيدات بان
الفتاه ستواصل تعليمها بعد الزواج اشار
اربعه وثمانون في المئه الى ان القاضي لم
يطلب اي ضمانات ومن الاردن سالنا الناس
برايك من هو المسؤول في زواج القاصرات
نتابع الاجابات
المسؤول الاول والاخير الاهل لانه القاصره
يعني معلوماتها بكون بالنسبه للزواج او
للحياه بتكون يعني محدوده
فالمسؤول الاول والاخير الاهل الاهل لانه
لازم الاهل يكونوا مسؤولين عن اولادهم باي
اشي ايا كان ان كان اشي صعب ان كان زواج
ان كان دراسه ان كان تعليم ان كان فيهم ان
كان جهل وبتصفى الاولاد نسبه يعني 40% انه
هو كمان عنده يكون عقل بيفهم بيعرف شو
بيعمل ايش لمصلحته ايش صح ايش غلط اول اشي
الحاله الاجتماعيه اللي بمر فيها والد
القاصر بيتجه انه يزوجها ليخلص من مصاريف
البيت الزائده من زواجها ومهرها اللي
بيكون هو ما يترتب عليه والد الزوج انه
بيحصل عليه ظروف الحياه صعبه
وفي جاهل للاولاد الامور ولك بدنا نسكر
البنت بالاساس كلها بترجع لظروف الحياه
صعبه هلا المسؤول عن زواج القاصرات اكثر
شيء اولياء الامور او المجتمع اللي بيفرض
حاله على اولياء الامور واقعنا ومجتمعنا
عرفت علي
ومن عمان تنضم الينا المدير العامه
للاتحاد المراه الاردنيه الست ناديه شمروخ
صباح الخير ست ناديه يعني السؤال الاول
رصدنا الكثير من المتزوجون او المتزوجات
القاصرات الذين يتمنى دراسهن بعد الزواج
ومرات بعد الخلف والابناء كيف تفسرين ذلك
وهل هذه قد تكون
مخرج او حل لهذه المشكله
صباح الخير يعطيكم الف عافيه المخرج عدم
تزويجها في سن الطفوله وليس المخرج الحلول
وكان المشكله قدريه المشكله ليست قدريه
المشكله
فيها بوقف الزواج المبكر ولذلك يعني لا
نبحث عن الحلول بعد تزويج الفتاه الاصل ان
تكمل الفتاه تعليمها الاصل ان يتم تطبيق
القانون المتعلق بالتعليم الحصول على
التعليم الاساسي على الاقل بكل فتى او فتى
ولذلك الان لا يتم تزويد تحسين الثامن
عشره لذلك يمكن مشكله بكل بساطه يعني لا
يمكن
ايجاد المشكله ومن ثم البحث عن الحلول طب
برايك دكتور اصل الطريقه الصحيحه في اوكي
ولكن بدات انه نجد يجب ان لا نزوج تلك
القاصره ولكن ما هو الحل كيف هي الطريقه
الطريقه بالمناسبه
فقط سريعا الى انا ظهرت تجهيز الفتيات هي
ظاهره مرتفعه جدا في دول الناميه ان تصل
الى 270 الف امراه قالت
امراه وكلهم جلهم في اسيا وافريقيا الوطن
العربي
مرتفعه في السودان الاردن يعني لا يرتبط
من الدول المناسبه
لكن
بس هل انا سمعت ان هناك قصص العديده اللي
صارت انه تزويج اللاجئات السوريات خصوصا
في الاردن ايضا حدثت هذه الظاهره تزويج
القاصرات السوريات الى رجال اكبر منهن
بكثير للتخلص من الفقر فهل تم احتضان هذه
المشكله او هل تم حل هذه المشكله بطريقه
ما
الفقر هو السبب الرئيسي الفقر والازمات
السياسيه والحروب بالتاكيد هي من الاسباب
المباشره لتجديد الفتيات لكن يعني انا زيك
سمعت الصراحه يعني حصل يمكن حادثتين او
ثلاثه تدخلنا فيها احنا اتحاد مراه ومنعنا
هذا الزواج
خليني بس اكمل الفكره لانه لا خليني اقول
انه بالنسبه للسوريات انه نسبه الزواج في
الاردن اليوم
حسب تقرير دائره قاده القضاه تسعه بوي
ثلاثة في الميه تسعه يتراجع عن السنه اللي
فاتت كانت 11% قبل اللجوء كانت 14 و15%
يعني تحميل اللجوء او اللاجئات السوريات
مسؤوليه ارتفاع سن الزواج هذا ليس يعني
دقيق ليس هنا يعني السوريين الاردنيين نفس
الثقافه نفس التقاليد صحيح يلعب دور الحرب
لعبه دور والتهجير لعب دور في انه يمكن
التفكير بالزواج بك لكن زواجه مبكر موجود
في سوريا قبل الحرب يعني حتى نكون واضحين
مش فقط الحرب السبب حوادث
كم انه تتدخل
ليس لنا سلطه ليس لنا سلطه الطريقه
الوحيده هو محاوله منع عندما نعلم وهنالك
لنا فروع منتشره في كل انحاء المملكه
وتتعامل مع النساء مع الفتيات عندما نعلم
ان هنالك زواج مبكر نحاول ايقافه بكل
الطرق نحاول ايقافه بالاقناع باقناع الاهل
باقناع الفتاه هذه الطريقه الوحيده لكن
الطريقه الاسلم والصحيحه لمنع الزواج بكري
وحمايه الفتيات من الزواج المبكر هو
رفع سبل الزواج 18 بدون اي تحفظات كما هو
حاصل في كل الدول العربيه كل الدول
العربيه رفعت سن الزواج الى 18 او 19 كما
هو حاله الجزائر او 17 كما هو الحال في
تونس لكن في الاردن يعتبر 15 هو بيقول
بدايه 16 يعني 15 لكن الصحيح هو رفع
الزواج ل 18 ومنع الفتيات تحسن الثامن عشر
نعم المدير العامه للاتحاد المراه
الاردنيه لهذا شمروخ شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المشاركه